hello everyone and welcome back to the
official random World Championship we
have a real treat in front of us this is
uh like something out of uh out of the
the Paul morphe era uh beautiful
attacking chess being played here only
one mistake by one of the players and
then uh everything just falls apart
truly yeah amazing chess uh so let's
dive straight into the position again a
very weird one one of the players even
said that uh uh the third day in a row
the positions they are getting are
absolutely disgusting I mean of course
they want to play Fisher random but this
is I mean what is this uh so let's dive
straight into it uh it's Ian pomichi
versus
and for the moment they've already
played two games now they're back one
both of them and now it's time for Jan
to strike back he has the white pieces
let's see what happened in this one uh
nepo opens with Pawn to G4 which makes
sense you open up your queen and also
the Bishops are placed on E1 and F1 you
wanna make them uh work as well so upon
the E5 controlling the center Works in
any chess variant we ignite the B3 and
now Pawn the G6 also opening up the
queen a little bit we have Pawn to D4
and now Knight to B6 we have uh Pawn to
H4 advancing the the king side pawns and
now Pawn to D5 I know the Rebecca grabs
the full Center the characters on E5
Queen captures on E5 and now okay the
Knight is actually on a square where the
Knight should be so Knight to F3
attacking the black queen so Queen to E7
we have E3 opening up the light Square
bishop and Bishop to G7 now we have Pawn
to G5 grabbing a lot of space here so
another big will have to figure out how
to develop the Knight to most likely
move the queen and then shift the Knight
to E7 uh Pawn to F5 you do not want a
backward spawn a stuck here if you know
everything just gets traded off the
board so either never will trade Alpha
song or you will have a beautiful Pawn
on F5 Queen H2 and now we have Bishop to
F7 we have Pawn to A3 taking away the B4
Square from The Black Queen but also
preparing Bishop V4 or in some lines
which could be important we have Queen
to E8 now freeing up D7 Square for the
Knight and now comes Knight beta D4 just
improving the position of the Knight
also H5 was a very nice idea uh we have
knighted the C4 now putting a lot of
pressure on that B2 pawn and now Bishop
to C3 with some nasty ideas of maybe
even even going some like Knight to C6
in the future could be uh could be
interesting opening up an attack towards
the the bishop here as the bishop is
unguarded or many weird discoveries so
here Bishop back to fade by another Beck
and now the shop characters and C4 the
bishop here for the moment isn't doing
all that much and the Knight is a
monster so we need to remove it Bishop
captures Pawn captures and now uh uh
Queen to E5 Yan centralizes the queen
offers a queen trade and if another Beck
would trade here this would be a great
position for Yan the knights beautifully
centralized the bishop very strong the
pawns already advanced on the king side
so uh obviously another back will not do
that that he will keep the Queens on the
board Knight the E7 and now you should
continue developing something like Rook
to D2 you Castle Queen uh Queen side you
play Rook to D1 double up on the D file
something
uh in that fashion but here Jan played
Bishop to B4 and uh this seems like a a
reasonable move as you are you know
controlling this diagonal you want to
trade down further but it actually
completely blunders the game but you
have to see why so feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out what the
unmissed here while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
C5 wins a piece here and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show uh
no it's not C5 right away it's uh
actually Rook to D5 first you attack the
queen you win the C5 square and now you
prepare C5 because white has to waste
time dealing with the attacked Queen and
there's no actual a good Square for the
queen if you go Queen F6 just Knight G8
attacks the queen again and if you put
the queen on h8 then the queen is on h8
and still you get C5 in and you just win
material end of the game so uh what
happened in the game was after Rook D5
young played Queen to F4 and now after
C5 attacking the bishop and Knight Yang
played Ponte E4 he attacks The Rook on
D5 and okay if the Rook moves then the
C5 Pawn will fall so here just F
captures on e4 and now Knights the E5
going after the bishop on F7 C Captain D
foreign grabs the Knight and creates
this massive Pawn chain in the center
Knight captures enough seven nipple
figures out how to save his piece and
now comes Knight to F5 blocking the
Queen's defense of the Knight and also
just uh enjoying a much better position
so what can nippo do here he plays
Bishop captures on f8 and now we have
Queen captures on F7 Queen captures an
f8 is also very strong for example if
Queen captures an f8 the Knight still
hanging and after Knight H6 you can just
castle queenside and I mean look at this
position this does not have to be
analyzed so okay after Bishop captures
an f8 another Rebecca decided to go
Queen captures on F7 instead now the
bishop is still hanging and uh how do
you play this well first a nice little
in-between move by nepo Queen captures
an E4 saying that okay if you capture
the bishop now I'm gonna capture your
Rook but now comes Queen side castles
and the Rooks are defending each other
with the bishop still hanging so Bishop
back to B4 or you play something else
but then you give up a piece so you have
to play Bishop to B4 and now Rook to E8
now attacking the a queen claiming the
only open file on the board that is the
e-file for the black Rook Queen to F4
and now Pawn to A5 just going after the
bishop Bishop to D2 and now Rook DTE E5
completely owning that e file and it's
very hard for uh for Yan to develop here
you still have to move the Rook you
still have the castle Queen side but I
mean in what order do you do those moves
he tries H5 uh it's a move uh I mean he
has to play something and now just Pawn
to C3 attacking the bishop weakening the
B2 Pawn weakening the A3 Pawn so B
captures on C3 and now uh interestingly
there is only one winning move for Abdul
satro of here and you have to be very
careful not to miss it so feel free to
pause the video once again and find the
winning idea for none direct while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not recapturing
we're doing something weird or even Rook
to E4 if you guys were considering that
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Queen to A2 that's
the good stuff now you're just gonna
capture an A3 delivered check and there
is no way out of this yeah whatever
you're playing uh it's pretty much the
same so here are C captures on D4 by on
Queen captures an A3 with Chuck Rook the
B2 and now uh a nice repetition of moves
because this move 28 and they gain
additional time at move 30 so you need
to reach that time control so Queen day
one check Rook the B1 Queen the A3 check
Rook the B2 these are the only moves for
nepo so he doesn't really have a choice
and only now Rook the B5 uh playing this
and move 30 so now time control has been
reached and now you also have increment
so you don't have to worry about messing
up the position because you're low on
time and here uh how are you defending
the The Rook uh you can't you should
just resign but nepo is always finds a
way he play is Bishop to C3 and it seems
like he's just you know given up he's
giving up a bishop but if you grab the
bishop then your Rook hangs on B5 so you
should be careful not to do stuff like
that so after Bishop to C3 now that we
just played Rook to E2 and he was in
this position on move 31 that
ianiponishi resigned in the game and yet
another victory for another of uh who
just uh is destroying everyone he this
is his third victory in a row against
the end so he has 3-0 against Jan he has
2-0 against Wesley so uh and uh I think
um yeah I'm pretty sure he only has one
draw or no it's uh it's a draw against
Wesley yeah it was that 100 move game
against Wesley uh that or I should just
check I don't want to trick you guys or
anything uh but yeah as we did cover it
so yeah it's only one draw against
Wesley and then uh four wins against
gretelson and now the third win in a row
against the only promises so I mean
incredible stuff yeah I know he he's a
reigning world rapid Champion but the
this is Fisher random I mean he is so
strong it's uh it's uh unfathomable I
mean such a such a strong player and
here we resign because now uh if you
move the bishop then just Queen captures
and B2 is Checkmate if you don't move
the bishop then captures Queen
characters
not on C2 but like literally anything
captures captures a few uh if you try to
defend the bishop then even Queen A1
check Rook to B1 and queen captures or
Rook captures his Checkmate so
absolutely everything is Checkmate here
uh so yeah a brilliant game by Abdul
Satur of Jan made that one uh one slight
uh inaccuracy or basically a uh you know
just a game losing blunder Bishop to B4
he missed Rook D5 and C5 and that was
enough to take down uh former World
Church Championship candidate uh and uh
also the the this year's World Church
Championship candidate uh Yani polishie
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really a wild one hope we see
many more uh games like this one uh I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to Sion and I would like to thank Jeff
Morrow Johann athlev Nathan uh Halsey
and Jacoby for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event until it finishes uh thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day